as part of the breakdown we are going to
see a game I think that you're going to
enjoy if it's by a famous player called
jihad chigorin was one of the best
masters in Russia in the turn of the
century and before his opponent is a
strong Russian master code called
Lebedev Lebedev oh yes and here you will
see a very nice demonstration by
chigorin of how a tame opening becomes a
very very wild game so without further
ado efore e5 Knight f3 Knight f6 I
notice that somehow on this tour that
I'm doing here I'm showing a lot of
Russian defense petrov the defense very
strange really wasn't intentional
so d4 first time I'm dealing with this
variation I think Knight takes e4 very
very normal
Bishop d3 white is about to regain the
pawn so first of all tempo over the
night black defends it white takes on e5
so now black play is one of the several
movies that he has at his disposal
Bishop to d6 again a very logical oh we
can see we have a completely symmetrical
position out of the opening and at first
you look at it you think how harmful can
this be to either player well the
symmetry continues even castles castles
and now I place in my opinion the only
move that makes sense in the position if
you don't do that then what help do you
have you have to somehow try to say that
the extra move means something he plays
c4 trying to undermine the position of
the knight on e4 and black plays the
most common move he just insist on
keeping a pawn in the center because he
takes d5 is just a very simple threat
and he holds it with c6 so far so normal
now White has two choices he can take on
d5 immediately and then follow it up
with Knight to c3 that's one very common
line here
or he can play the move in the game 93
first of course they each have their
pluses and minuses obviously if you take
on d5 first then the pawn takes the
knight c3
then after Knight takes three c3 pawn
takes c3 black will have some counter
play on the C file there's going to be a
row coming and the C pawn is going to be
slightly weak of course it's been proven
that white has his own chances by going
rook to b1 and trying to tickle the pawn
on b7 a little bit okay that is a
completely different variation of course
so he plays Knight to c3 combining a
double attack on the D pawn and tonight
on e4 and instead of just reacting black
just tries to resolve it without losing
time and he takes on c3 very normal
white takes back and now he took on e5
okay this move is somewhat questionable
I have to admit probably the most normal
move is just to continue developing it
in in a normal way but he says he wants
to compromise the white pawn structure
and anybody was here for one of my
recent lectures I think it was even in
the same class I was talking about a
checklist of how to look at a chess
position and I mentioned pawn structure
but I mentioned that before that comes
peace activity so as important the pawn
structure may be having fewer chains
rather than more chains because then
those chains are very vulnerable the
pawns are very vulnerable excuse me the
piece activity sometimes almost all the
time outweighs the pawn structure this
will be one great example for that so
blacks taking the knight take back now
we took on c4 as well and the bishop
takes on c4 very well so this is
basically is our starting position when
you look at the position someplace I
sometimes ask my students about this
position what do you think about it and
true to their youth energic a youth edge
it's a youth and very little education
they say oh this has to be very good for
black his King is safe he has three
pawns defending it and the Queen side
wing is also very protective white on
the other hand has upon laid to upon on
c3 the pawn on e5 we're not sure if it's
a weak or strong and the appraise box
they kind of forget that if the the cost
that black paid for those bonds is great
peace activity right now white is
developed extra is a bishop on c4 he has
two bishops especially noticed that all
the dark squares around the board are
dominated by the bishop on c1 we don't
know if the bishop is gonna go this way
or this way again it depends and black
has a little some problems with
development
let me demonstrate some variations for
example in the game he played the move
Queen II seven you wanted to maintain
the Queen's on the board and the
question is what would have happened if
you went for the Queen trade it looks
like hey when you see what happened in
the game you think wow if only the
Queen's were off the board that would
have been so beautiful but you'll see
that it's not that simple so let's
pretend that he would have taken and
takes and you think wow now the pawn
structure should tell even more because
the more pieces are off the board the
more obvious the weakness of the pawns
are supposed to be however black has
some problems with his development let's
take a look at some sub lines
Bishop F if Bishop f5 tried to get the
bishop out rook d6 very very active 97
attempting to complete the development
pony 6 the pawn on e5 was attacked and
we are getting rid of it
so already you can see that black has
some issues the night on d7 is being
attacked not only by the pawn but also
by the rock so I can just play Bishop
takes Bishop takes oopsie and then of
course the night is gone on d7 however
if the knight just moves anywhere after
ecigs let's say for example here then I
play pawn takes pawn check notice that
the bishop is protecting it so the rook
is very uninterested in taking and when
the King moves I can perhaps play Bishop
b3 now White has an extra pawn and on
top of that he can use his Bishop either
from a3 or from g5 e7 and black is
nearly lost very very unappetizing from
blacks point of view so what else can be
done
oops in this position after takes let's
say he plays 97 first
doesn't allow the rook to go to v6 and
attack everything and in this position
again 695 the only move because again
notice the double attack the pawn is
attacking the knight and also the pawn
on f7 if you let me think they're not
they'll be wonderful if you move the
knight I'll take on f7 and again with a
totally winning position for example
let's say something like this check and
let's say I guess Bishop e3 if you take
my bishop I'll take your rook and the
route can't move not very fun so you
will have to play 95 the only move I
should also mention by the way just I'm
sure most of you see it that pawn takes
pawn is also out of the question because
Bishop check for King the knight and the
King when the King moves Bishop takes on
d7 for example like this like this and
trying to pin the bishop is also not
very useful
I guess well actually maybe you could do
that because if Bishop g4 done bishop
takes g4 but I guess probably a better
move would be to play rook takes d7 rook
takes d7 Bishop takes Bishop takes if
you play rook d8 trying to attack my
bishop and checkmate then I come here
and I'm stopping the maid saving my
bishop and stopping the maid they'll be
no mate soon my bishop will come out
right also I can just play Bishop III
and not a good example if you take my
bishop I will take your rook and again
they'll be no mate so it's amazing how
with so little material it doesn't take
much for block to get into a totally
losing position already from position
like this you looked at oh I traded
Queens how much damage can I have after
all this rook is back home this bishop
is back home and the rook is operating
from a distance but again it's it's a
big problem
so we'll analyze one more time the
mainline after 95 now the night is out
of danger defending the pawn on f7 and
attacking the bishop on c4 e 7
just following the anon claim that if
you make a bigger threat than your
opponent you can just ignore his many
people just automatically move the
attack beast like the bishop but of
course it's not necessary
well the rook has exactly one move to go
to you and then rook d8 they're not a
beautiful tempo because as you notice
Bishop c4 is attacked but we can just
afford to attack the roof back black
doesn't look very good Bishop f5 how
else to defend the rock is a bishop out
and now Bishop g5 and not a beautiful
move quick development if Knight takes
here rook takes a eight rook takes a
eight and the last piece comes into the
game rook to d1 and the rook is about to
visit the DA square black can just
resign very very bad position after here
here Knight here bishop here everything
is falling apart just a beautiful
beautiful position for white so again
this these variations just go to
illustrate how terrible blacks position
is it's like the pawn structure really
does not count so that's why he was
maybe reluctant to trade Queens but he
won't notice that keeping the Queens on
the board is definitely not a picnic
either he want Queen e7 and again white
needs to think okay what do I want to do
why didn't he play 27 because if you
move the Queen elsewhere already you
have Bishop a3 tickling the rock and the
rook will have some difficulty so now
first he wants to prevent Bishop e3
white says well now I need to do several
things I really want to activate my
Bishop and let me do so by playing the
very nice move a4 now my rook is
protecting the a3 square so of course
the threat is this with a beautiful
skewer black better do something about
it and in the game he did something
about it the question is some of you
might say wait a minute
can the Queen just take the pawn on e5
this looks like a free gift but again
it's sometimes just by intuition even if
you can't really calculate
like you I can tell you that any Grand
Master or Master looking in the position
would have the feeling that this has to
work for white because again look at all
the black Petes is spectating the white
pieces can spring out very quickly it's
going to get a lot of time for the pawn
and the consequences are going to be
dire so in the game he went through d8
well I can also analyze Bishop e6 but I
want to see first of all Queen takes in
d5 and let's take a look what would have
happen after this I think maybe rook F
to e1 looks very convincing the position
is just very groggy for black when he
moves he already has to account for
Bishop a3 and the rook will have a big
problem where to move to very difficult
situation really a tough position for
black you cannot just go on hunting when
all your pieces are back I'm sure that
White has more winning moves like maybe
maybe even Bishop Bishop e3 immediately
is also looking very very strong bad
position so alternatively Bishop e6 then
Bishop a3 c5 the only move not to lose
material of course and then simply
Bishop d3 the bishop is already changing
diagonals looking very hungrily at the
pawn on 87 Knight develop f4 Tao spawns
are about to storm and after rook b8
Queen c2 temple moving away from the pin
and attacking the pawn on 8 7 g 6r ukai
1 all the white pieces are in the game
and I can tell you that very shortly
white is going to start pushing his F
pawn right here not at this point is
protected and a very miserable position
black has a real bad position look at
all the dark squares weaknesses black
does not have a describe a ship white
still has his so at the right time the
bishop might just shift once the pawn
goes here the bishop will probably shift
and change diagonals black is very very
much in trouble
so he played rook d8 and white played
the most aggressive one with his queen
of course his queen is attacked on d1 he
has many good moves with the Queen but
h5 has to be the right one not only is
he very clearly attacking the pawn on f7
right now of course is defended well but
he is eyeing it
he is also supporting the g5 square for
his bishop if he had another freedom he
would love to play Bishop to g5 again
with a beautiful secure so easy to
understand so the rook changes position
he doesn't want to get fork he played
rook to e8 Bishop Bishop e3 notice that
white is really tempting black to take
the pawn on e5 he's telling him please
please take my pawn and of course now he
cannot hear Queen had to go to d7 well
yeah
it's really sad if he takes the pawn of
course I can take on f7 with my queen
with my bishop I can do whatever I want
it's just winning immediately if you
play Queen to c7 then of course my
bishop can come to d6 with a tempo and
the Queen will have to go to d7 anyway
just the bishop improve his position I'm
sure you can already understand what is
going on here and what why I'm showing
you this game now what the white pawn
structure vulnerable as it may be kind
of a weak born isolated and I saw that
there untouchable in the meantime blacks
lacking the lack of development and a
little shaky King tell the story of the
game so Queen d7 as we said Luke a d1
and not a beautiful tempo and Queen f5
the Queen must defend itself and stay in
touch with the f7 pawn why played Queen
h4 retreating and now he played Queen
takes e5 of course very very unpleasant
but of course there was a threat for
example if you would just develop his
Bishop Bishop e6 trying to challenge the
bishop and trade pieces he would
immediately face the unpleasant Bishop
d3 with another skewer the Queen and the
pawn on 87 when the Queen moves
somewhere maybe take on e5 or I don't
know what and then taking on 87 as a
matter of fact you can imagine that
something like this has just made on the
move the bishop doesn't let the King
escape further so very very easy to
understand how vulnerable the position
is for black cannot complete this
development for a while now so he
decided to gamble and take this pawn and
I think this is where you saw Sarah on
one of our commentators for the US
Championships and also also a frequent
German resident says died on a full
stomach
basically you eat and then you you pay
so f4 they're not a very great move
again notice that it's not so simple for
white you try to challenge on the file
because the Queen and the rook are lined
up against it emiru coming to e1 is
going to be answered with Queen take c1
with very bad consequences for white
this back rank is very weak so on we go
boom fr F 4 and again the Queen has
several moves and none of them is
promising let's pretend in the game we
played Queen f6 trying to trade Queens
but let's see what would have happened
if you were just taking another pawn
continued with the axiom of dying on a
full stomach and now if you look at the
position white is down two pawns
what's more both of his bishops are
attacked on a 3 and C 4 but again when
Black has all his pieces back home doing
nothing this is not going to work white
would play rook to d8 threatening the
rook with checkmate so there's no time
to take either Bishop Bishop d7 trying
to defend
the rock Queen d7 taking advantage the
fact that the rook is pinned you cannot
take the Queen obviously you expose your
King to check so that's out and very
very unpleasant just no more move even
if you can somehow defend the rock let's
say you play Knight a6 ok then Bishop d7
is gone f7 is gone everything is being
attacked you're gonna lose everything
you have so again black could not do
that
so he went Queen f6 we have to say that
black for now is defending very
reasonably but again I wanted to see it
to do a comparison between the two
armies White has a safer King than
blacks for sure because nothing is
attacking the white King and here all
the bishops and the Queen's are all over
it look at the development on the Queen
side that's a very telling story of a
problem and look at how the bishops and
the rocks are very active and the Queen
is now also active but it's attacked and
what did Y do look he took a shocking
move because what do we know we are
always told don't trade pieces when you
have the initiative if you trade you
left your opponent off the hook the more
pieces of the board the lessee has to
worry about threats but again you have
to be flexible minded in chess and this
is a great example of that
again it belongs to the category that I
love to use of trading one advantage for
another yes you get rid of the MVP the
Queen's are off my great queen on h4 has
to be traded but the lack of development
and the fact that White has the
initiative it's his move is gonna cost
black dearly so he trades takes for a
moment some people will say black is
happy but after the next move I'm pretty
certain that he realized that he is not
gonna be happy because the King said is
now compromised rook f3 look at the
harmony among the white pieces the two
bishops the two rooks nob this rook is
about to visit on g3 the black King is
starting to feel the draft not fun so he
played Bishop e6
seems like a very reasonable move what
else can he do he cannot stop rook g3
check anyways
and he's at least trying to kind of
eliminate the bishop on sc4 do something
active complete his development and not
white does a very nice finish
he plays rook to g3 check King h8 and
just when again it seems like maybe
black is somehow patching things up
white comes with what I call a dream
crusher the next move just finishes the
game take a good look before I show it
you in class also the people at home
because it's really fun to make a move
like this over the chessboard at least I
think so more looking and Bishop e7 a
beautiful a beautiful beautiful move
what is the point of this well in the
game hue and h5 but I'll explain why
first of all of course we are
threatening mate on the move arthritis
Bishop takes f6 checkmate if you even
dream of taking this then I have another
beautiful mate by playing rook here you
only have this move and then of course I
take and it's checkmate the King is just
stuck again look at the development
lastly after Bishop here if you play
Knight d7 and you say well look i
completed my development and my knight
is defending the pawn on f6 you can
imagine that white simply eliminates the
defender who cares about material when
we have made and after Bishop takes this
is checkmate
just a beautiful beautiful use of the
bishops and the piece activity well in
the game he didn't fare much better
after h5 he is trying to release his
King so the King has some moves because
otherwise he would be checkmate in and
check and that was it now black realized
that even with the escape he is not
really saving the game why because after
King eight seven his bishop that was
just sleepy for a little bit changes
diagonals he is gonna go Bishop to d3
check no good way to block it I mean if
you put your Bishop on f5 I will just
take it that wouldn't solve anything and
when you finally
which the promised land on h6 an escape
square then comes Bishop g7 checkmate
again a beautiful utilization of an
attack with minimalistic forces just a
beautiful beautiful attacking game by
chigorin any questions about the game
no you understood it I'm sure yeah it's
a very kind of a self-explanatory game
you see the Peace activity even without
Queens you understand that when we look
at the variation analyzed should black
have taken on d1 and then you see that
even when he doesn't he still gets in
trouble his King gets in trouble since
we have extra time and the game ended
quickly I am going to show you a
position and really what I thought was
one of a very very beautiful combination
and again taking advantage of peace play
and better development we look at this
position and what do we see we
understand immediately the difference
between the Kings one King is stuck on
e7 unable to castle notice that
crisscross between the bishop on g5 and
the Queen on a3
just amazing we see that the King on g1
is untouchable and all the white pieces
save for the rook on a1 that has yet to
move are doing something very aggressive
towards the center towards the King in
the meantime the black pieces are much
weaker notice the lack of harmony among
the pieces they are just they cannot do
one thing together the only thing that
they can do together is try to defend
against the black weakness but even that
is not for long the bishop on g7 is
biting on granite just facing a very
strong chain of pawns the knight on g4
looks very threatening but the night
alone can't do anything as a matter of
fact is only legal move that doesn't
lose material is going backwards this
way that's not an impressive night
notice that the rooks are unconnected
and the Queen on d7 is also not
impressive
but we'd like to move how to what to do
and White has a beautiful continuation
he thinks how am I gonna get my rooks
involved how am I going to open up the
position of course one of the first
things that you guys want to think about
when you have an advantage in
development how do I open up the
position if miking is safe and this king
in the center
I just wish white would have paid money
to see this pawn gone the pawn on e5 he
wishes that he could just have
disposition just a pawn away so of
course that's a bit illegal we can't do
that here the machine is whistling in
protest and what he does he just pushes
it the pawn goes forward to e6
now of course black must take this pawn
whether he likes it or not if the Queen
doesn't move we'll take it if you move
the Queen away then after a takes f7 you
have opened up the rook to the
vulnerable knight on e7
he is already attacked twice and
defended twice but once the rook will
join if the pawn gets to take here it'll
be three for two and the night is gonna
go and black is going to just die
immediately
so he must take for a moment more you
might say wait a minute how did that
open the position it looks like it's
just closed again but again when so many
pieces are attacking there's just
there's always a combination watch the
next move it's one of it's always the
most beautiful move in a position when
you can strike your opponent at the most
defended square if you think what is
black's most offended square on the
board it's a square that's defended one
two three four different times and what
is attacking it only once and he is just
capturing he's just doing it watch
Knight takes d5 it's almost a rude kind
of move are very very impolite move he
strikes at the most defendants grandest
act there's no support for this Knight
and black and take with the pawn he can
take with the Queen he can take with the
knight he can take with the pawn and you
think yourself what the heck how can you
do something like that
well the answer is very simple all
captures are losing watch one by one I
think it's just totally beautiful if you
take with the Queen then obviously the
answer is Queen take c7 checkmate thank
you very much the Queen has left the
defender that was easy right yeah okay
alternatively maybe you can take with
the e pawn ah but then the rook opened
the e-file and guess what rook takes a
seven if Queen takes Queen takes mate
and if you move the King away I'm just
going to take your Queen we check at the
minimum well of course why
crushing so that capture is also out hmm
what happen if we take with this night
the night was that that was the trouble
child on e7
well the night that was defending the
pawn on g6 that the pawn on f7 moved now
we can just play Bishop take g6 and
notice that the King has no legal moves
you cannot capture the bishop on g6
black will have to give up his queen
but it's not just giving up his Queen
because I'm not gonna rush to take it
most likely I will just go rook takes
pawn check notice that the Queen cannot
take it's pinned and total collapse just
a complete rush by white so okay this
move is also out so so far we couldn't
take with the Queen we couldn't take
with the e pawn we couldn't take with
the knight
how about it we'll try the last piece
with this pawn and here the answer is
well now the rook is stuck on the file
the bishop cannot take the pawn on g6
because it's protected by the knight but
because that Knight is so vulnerable or
et7
and it's only the defender is the Queen
other than the king but the King can't
capture when two pieces are attacking it
now we play a simple deflection move the
bishop is the bishop is just teasing the
Queen of course the idea is I'm about
I'm peeling the Queen to the king if you
decide to take it oops sorry
then Queen texty seven is again
checkmate and if you try to do the last
thing that you might be able to do and
that put the knight on c6 to block the
file and not get made it I just take it
and you are exactly back to square one
after Queen takes widow without a knight
this is always made so just a tremendous
strike at the most defended spot after
each six 90s d5 and now what to do
really
there is no move all the moves Lucy
takes d5 Queen takes d5 C takes d5 and
you can't the problem is that you can't
even not take because I'm attacking the
knight on on e7 a bunch of times I'm
attacking it once twice
three times we know it can't move
because Bishop takes g6 is a disaster so
in this position black can just resigned
with a clear conscience it's all over
just a beautiful combination okay guys
thank you very much for your time I hope
you enjoyed the game in the position and
I'll see you next time